Good morning, Hank.
It's Tuesday.
I'm sorry if this video's a little bit disjointed,
the linings of my brain and spinal cord are
inflamed, which is pretty uncomfortable.
Okay, so last week I sent out a message saying
that I was going to miss my Vlogbrothers video
due to hospitalization, and then I went back
to being in, like, the worst pain of my life.
And then, while I was staring at the ceiling
begging for the pain to go away, the internet
diagnosed me with Ebola.
Like, "John Green Ebola" was a trending search
on Twitter.
People I knew in real life texted me and were
like, "Do they know what it is yet?
Is it confirmed?"
Then I was just like "Barf," and I don't mean
that figuratively.
So ten days before getting what turned out
to be viral meningitis, I was in Ethiopia,
which shares a continent with countries like
Guinea and Sierra Leone where there is currently
an Ebola outbreak.
Now, never mind that Ethiopia is as far from
this outbreak as England is from Afghanistan.
I had recently been on the same continent
as Ebola, and now I was in the hospital, ergo
Ebola.
Quick side note, Hank, Ebola is a very serious
health crisis in West Africa, but more people
are going to die of malaria today than have
died from Ebola in the last ten years combined.
So, anyway, Hank, when I went to the hospital
the doctors were very concerned, I mean, I
might have meningitis, or malaria, or typhoid,
or dengue fever, all of which can be fatal.
But they weren't worried that I had Ebola.
This is my point though, even if I had Ebola
it wouldn't have been a big deal!
I mean, I guess, it would have been a big
deal to me or my family.
It wouldn't have been a big deal from a public
health perspective.
Like, here's what the news would have said,
"An American has contracted Ebola.
Shortly after returning from Africa, Ebola
Johnnie went to Orlando, Florida and signed
books for sixteen hundred people at a Harry
Potter convention, all of whom are now veritably
dripping with the disease."
But here's the thing, Hank, if I had somehow
magically gotten Ebola in Ethiopia, which,
to reiterate, is impossible, I wouldn't have
given it to any of those sixteen hundred people
at LeakyCon.
For one thing, you aren't contagious if you
aren't symptomatic, and also, I didn't share
bodily fluids with any of those sixteen hundred
people.
Call me old fashioned, Hank, but I like to
keep bodily fluid sharing within my nuclear
family.
Ebola is spreading because it's often being
treated in healthcare facilities with no running
water or latex gloves, which makes sterilization
functionally impossible.
Just having water and bleach would prevent
a lot of these Ebola cases.
This isn't some terrifying, uncontrollable
superbug.
There's mounting evidence that there might
be treatments or vaccines or both within a
year.
But the most important thing to remember,
Hank, is that this outbreak is happening because
of poor health infrastructure.
Hank, I think we're obsessed with Ebola partly
because it's novel, partly because it's so
fatal, but partly because most diseases endemic
to the developing world seem Other.
I mean, more than half a million people are
going to die of malaria this year, but unlike
Ebola, we don't think of malaria as a disease
that's "coming for us."
Whatever the hell "us" means.
Now, of course, Ebola isn't coming for this
vague "us" either.
It's not going to spread widely in the U.S.
or Europe.
But, regardless, when Americans try to make
the Ebola outbreak about America, we do a
great disservice to ourselves AND to the communities
actually affected by this horrible disease.
In Liberia and Guinea and Sierra Leone, health
workers have to choose between abandoning
their work and putting themselves and their
kids at risk for Ebola.
And they have to make that choice because
of inadequate infrastructure and supplies.
Addressing THAT problem instead of freaking
out about the disease coming to whoever "us"
is will actually reduce Ebola transmission.
And, in the process, it will also save many,
many lives from malaria, and typhoid, and
also meningitis.
Which brings me back to my infected brain
lining.
Hank, it turns out that I almost certainly
got meningitis, not in Ethiopia, but in Florida.
Oh, Orlando, city of my youth, city of my
inflamed meninges.
Hank, it's going to take a little bit for
my meninges to completely de-itis.
So, I apologize if I'm not around as much
in the coming weeks.
But, nerdfighters, thank you so much for putting
stuff on your heads to cheer me up.
It really did the trick when I desperately
needed it.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.